guys I cannot believe the Apple gimped
this new iPad this much apple finally
redesigned the budget iPad but how much
better is it than the ninth generation
that they still sell because they raised
the price point of the new one up to 450
dollars well we're gonna compare
everything starting off with the design
the speakers the displays the brand new
camera system the performance and some
people said that Apple capped the A14
and much more like I mentioned we've
been waiting for this iPad for a while
now and apple gave it to us including
some brand new colors that pop way more
than before so take a look at that oh my
goodness that's my first impression this
is even Bolder than what I saw online it
looked bold before but geez this blue
okay I'm gonna have to compare it to the
iPads
um but we'll do that in separate video
so make sure to subscribe if you guys
want to see comparison against the iPad
Air 5 but my goodness this thing pops
like crazy I think some people are gonna
buy this new iPad just for the updated
design and these new colors compared to
the cheaper option now obviously we have
the flat sides there all around it looks
more modern and clean we now have stereo
speakers so you see them at the bottom
there and then also at the top where the
old one doesn't have that and we have
USB type c which we're gonna test out
how fast is this port Apple did mention
it and haven't seen anybody test that so
I'm excited for those two tests on the
back it's completely flat and you guys
see the camera is much larger than the
tiny one before I'll also have to test
that out not a lot of people shoot stuff
with their iPads but my kids do they're
just complaining how this iPad sucks in
terms of video quality we also have a
much larger microphone the SMART
connector is a lot larger now and
unfortunately we do not have a headphone
jack like the previous one does so that
might be a deal breaker for some people
now we also have that touch ID button
that is much larger at the top here just
like the iPad Air whereas the older iPad
has that touch ID built in on the front
the buttons are larger and easier to
find and press compared to the previous
iPad and as far as Dimensions the new
iPad is actually slightly wider but
shorter and it is actually lighter and
slightly thinner than the old design but
in the hand it doesn't feel thinner
because of the squared off edges
compared to these rounded ones so I
think this one's a little bit more
comfortable looking at the front of the
iPads you see that the new one has even
bezels all around compared to the older
design where we actually have Slimmer
bezels on the sides but much thicker on
the top and bottom because of that touch
ID and that camera there now I'm going
to cover the differences in displays
here soon but first I have to test out
the differences in speakers so let's go
ahead and take take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there you guys go let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below now the difference having stereo
and not is huge with the older iPad you
hear all the sound from one side whereas
the new one it's Stereo Plus we have way
more bass it might be slightly louder
I'm not sure but what surprised me is
that the older iPad design it has a lot
more high frequencies whereas this one
sounds slightly muted in the highs now
I'm curious does the iPad Air have much
better speakers we will find out in that
comparison but overall it's a win
because that was probably the biggest
downside of this iPad so some people if
you watch a lot of videos playing games
this might be enough to upgrade or buy
this one now our other biggest complaint
was the display so getting into that you
would think that it would be a big
update we have 10.9 inches compared to
10.2 but it really isn't because both of
these displays have the same exact Peak
brightness of 500 nits instead of 6 600
or more on the other iPads the details
of the screens are exactly the same 264
PPI they're both limited to srgb for
color accuracy and both of them are 60
hertz not pro motion 120 hertz or 90.
now the worst thing is that the new iPad
still has a non-laminated display which
means there is a gap between the glass
at the top and the screen itself now
that is bad because you get a lot more
reflectivity the screen doesn't seem
right up there next to you it also
lowers contrast and increases
reflectivity and it is bad for apple
pencil users because where you place the
actual pencil isn't where the actual
drawing is being made especially looking
slightly off to the side you see that
it's not exactly there like it is if you
have a laminated display now you guys
may have noticed the delay and lag you
can saw that right there too where your
drawing doesn't actually keep up with
the pencil itself and that's because of
the 60 hertz and because we're using the
old apple pencil and what sucks is that
the new one still uses the original
apple pencil that came out in
2015. now I want to test out if the
delay is any better but I can't use this
because you actually need an adapter now
in order to be able to pair it and
charge this apple pencil because now we
have that USB type-c port now you would
think that Apple would include it in the
box if you buy a new iPad but nope it is
not here you have to buy this separately
for nine dollars and even when
pre-orders open at 5am I ordered it
right away it would only come on
November 2nd or November 1st if I spent
eight bucks on shipping which I did now
apple is selling an updated package with
this old apple pencil that has the
adapter included but that is also only
shipping in November even if I ordered
it right away so that sucks now we do
have this nice braided cable included in
the box which is cool but I would rather
not have the braided cable and have the
adapter included in the Box as so many
people already have these you can buy
them for cheap online but nope we need
to have an adapter now to use this apple
pencil and pair it now what we should
have is compatibility with the apple
pencil 2 that can magnetically attach
and charge just like on the iPad Air but
nope that is not here and you have to
use the old one which is absolutely
crazy now once I finally get the adapter
we are going to Compare the Apple pencil
original to the 2 with the iPad Air that
uses it to see how much better of an
experience that is so make sure you guys
are subscribed with the Apple also added
a brand new keyboard for this iPad now
that is because the cameras have finally
switched from a landscape setup to a
horizontal setup like this so with that
keyboard you have a nice centered shot
unlike the iPad Pros where you're
looking at the screen it looks like
you're looking way off from the side now
you may be asking where is my keyboard
why am I not showing it off well I
ordered it at the same time as the iPad
right at pre-order open should have came
today but it is delayed and it's going
to come sometime hopefully soon I might
try to get my hands on one earlier get
it locally so we can compare to the
magic keyboard but that definitely is a
bummer nothing is expensive as well now
with that said let's go ahead and test
out the quality of these cameras and the
microphones this is the quality of the
front facing camera and microphones
holding it like it normally would of
course I'm being cut off so I'd have to
raise it up a bit maybe move over and
try to look like this and this is the
quality of the new 10 generation iPad
holding it exactly the same it is
centered uh you see my whole face and
you guys let me know down below which
one sounded better in terms of
microphones now on the back the nightgen
iPad has this tiny eight megapixel
camera compared to a much larger 12
megapixel on the iPad 10. here's a
sample shot of Vadim the iPad 10 gen
definitely looks better a lot more
contrast a lot more detail now it's not
great on the new iPad but it is better
in every way and I also did a zoom shot
and look at that no wonder my kids were
complaining about the camera quality
when they were trying to make little
videos and edit them together and now
let's get into performance both of these
have 64 gigabytes of storage and I want
to see how fast is storage and how fast
is this new USB type-c port it looks
like as far as read we have about 100
megabytes per second faster on the
tension iPad but for right it is about
70 megabyte per second faster not much
and that is actually a really slow speed
for a USB type-c port if you're
transferring files onto the device now
I'm going to do a transfer test but
unfortunately I could even get my SSD
which is not Thunderbolt to connect to
this iPad through lightning maybe I need
an adapter usually people are just using
like a SD card reader plugged into that
Apple sells connecting it to the iPad 10
it shows up right away and works so
let's go ahead and grab this file here
and we are going to move it to the iPad
I'm going to hit copy and start my
stopwatch here we'll see how long that
takes oh my goodness it says 11 minutes
and 11 seconds so far for a file that is
under 25 gigabytes it's just one video
clip which is the easiest file to
transfer because it's not split up
unfortunately we don't have a readout
telling us how fast the transfer is
going but it's settled in now and it
does look like it's just over 11 minutes
now on my Mac this took exactly one
minute to transfer guys I did the math
and based on the file size and the time
it's taking that's going at 41.25
megabytes per second that is USB 2
speeds and we're not limited by the
internal SSD here because that's at
278mb per second did Apple really put a
USB 2 connector in this usb-c port that
is absolute insanity if they limited it
this bad and it does seem like they did
this is absolutely crazy guys I cannot
believe the Apple gimped this new iPad
this much that took 10 minutes and 27
seconds and a half to transfer a file
under 25 gigabytes
that is I would say almost heartbreaking
to see a new iPad that's gonna be around
for so long being limited just to make
the iPad Air better now we're going to
test this again with the iPad Air when
we do that comparison but I just can't
believe in 2022 almost 2023 we're still
using USB 2.0 in this port look at this
guys I'm moving the file now from the
iPad to the SSD and it's saying it's
gonna take over 11 minutes to do so and
you guys saw uh the read speed from the
iPad is over 700 right so it's not
limiting at all and it's still taking
this long I just wanted to confirm it
that is insane and now let's see how
this new A14 compares to the previous
a13 this one also has four gigs of RAM
compared to three I'm gonna go ahead and
run geekbenches CPU Benchmark all right
guys we have the scores and it's also
not as good as I wanted to see we have 3
thousand two hundred seventy seven
compared to 39.50 for multi-core score
that's a 20 difference not a huge bump
but and this 10 iPad 814 is actually
about 10 slower than the iPad Air 4 with
the A14 as far as single core score we
have almost a 20 difference as well
about 18 there so not huge let's go
ahead and run the compute test to test
out the graphics I'm curious how that's
going to be and there you go that is
what I wanted to see we have 7 300
versus 12
668. that is 73 better metal graphics
performance testing out a lot of
different tasks here that is way higher
and that is on the iPad Air 4's level of
Graphics even though Apple only said
it's a 10 increase compared to this one
no we're seeing 73. with that said let's
go ahead and test out gaming performance
I'm gonna run the extreme unlimited test
that way it's running the same
resolution and off screen let's see how
this does in terms of gaming and we have
disappointment once again now you look
at this here we have 10.9 compared to
12.2 that's about 20 faster not a huge
difference I mean 20 20 but the iPad Air
4 with the same A14 was 20 faster than
this one that means that apple is
slowing down the chip if you're doing an
extended load not even that long in this
case compared to what we had a few years
ago and the M1 iPad Air well that is
about 30 frames per second that's two
and a half three times faster in terms
of gaming performance so this thing is
definitely being slowed down and that is
a bummer that puts this new iPad 10
generation in a really tough spot
because we showed you guys they can buy
an iPad Air for for 429 dollars
refurbished with a three month money
back guarantee or the M1 version for not
much more money so if this thing was 329
dollars like this one 350 even 399 it
might be okay but at 450 bucks having
the CPU be capped the graphics uh be
capped as well if you're gaming and then
that USB port it's just quite a bit of
money now if you're somebody doesn't
care about having the old generation
apple pencil you're not even going to
use it or a keyboard case things like
that you just want a basic iPad 329 is
still not a bad deal for the ninth
generation that you could buy you can
even get it for Less we'll link it down
below at 450 bucks this thing is better
in a lot of ways the screen's not much
better but having those speakers having
that centered camera
um having just this new design it is
definitely nice to have but you are
paying a premium for it especially with
the other limitations so personally I
like this device it is just a bummer
that Apple raised the price that high it
and the fact that we have the new webcam
it's great for that keyboard but the
keyboard is also 250 dollars so you're
spending some serious coin to get the
new design and the iPad ears are looking
like a much better deal now with these
limitations so my thought is is it worth
it for some people yes but not for
everybody and we definitely have to
compare it to the iPad Air so if you
guys want to see that click that Circle
above check out one of those great
videos right over there that's been
maxed and I'll see you in the next one
foreign